even with the infighting Democrat among
the Republicans the Democrats are just
looking absolutely terrible right now
one of their last shots in the midterm
election
was was to try to exploit the incident
at the Pelosi home as evidence that the
Republicans are terrorists and Nazis and
fascists and it's a threat to democracy
and so you remember there was this
incident that took place at the Pelosi
home Nancy Pelosi wasn't there her
husband was there there was a strange
man who seemed to be a kind of
nudist Berkeley hemp jewelry maker who
with BLM signs and pride Flags in his
window who nevertheless was called a
right-wing person and he was yelling
where's Nancy and there was a hammer and
Joe Biden the president of the United
States gave a whole speech about this
insinuating that this attack is just
evidence that the Republicans are a
threat to democracy this was their their
real final pitch
in the election but the details never
quite added up
you're telling me there was no security
at the Pelosi house this guy just got in
seems unlikely possible but unlikely and
then you tell there's they don't have
security cameras so we can't see this
and then the the dispatch when the 911
call was made the dispatch said that
Paul Pelosi said that he knew the guy
and his name was David and he was a
friend of his but he didn't know the guy
but he knew the stuff about him and the
whole thing
it was just kind of weird wasn't it well
it just got weirder because there's an
NBC news report
that was up
a long TV report about the new details
that have emerged in the investigation
take a listen
source is familiar with what unfolded in
the Pelosi residence now revealing when
officers responded to the high priority
call they were seemingly unaware they've
been called to the home of the speaker
of the house after a knock and announce
the front door was opened by Mr Pelosi
the 82 year old did not immediately
declare an emergency or tried to leave
his home but instead began walking
several feet back into the foyer toward
the assailant and away from police it's
unclear if the 82 year old was already
injured or what his mental state was say
sources according to court documents
when the officer asked what was going on
defendant smiled and said everything's
good but instantaneously a struggle
ensued as police clearly saw David depap
strike Paul Pelosi in the head with a
hammer after tackling the suspect
officers rushed to Mr Pelosi who was
lying in a pool of wide
what
so the police get the call
and they say they don't know it's the
pelosiers but they get the call they
know it's an important person
and then there was this question who
opened the door
the police didn't bust in so someone
opened the door who is the person opened
the door Paul Pelosi himself opened the
door
but he didn't run out saying oh my gosh
there's this guy he's attacking me help
me officer help me he didn't he didn't
even say this is an emergency come on
he opens the door
greets the police officers and then
walks back
to this Berkeley nudist guy the attacker
and then they're all kind of chatting
and then the attacker attacks him in
front of the police
so he hadn't the attacker hadn't
attacked Paul Pelosi before the police
got there
that's kind of weird and the whole
the whole thing is just raises way more
questions than it provides answers and
NBC News went on even further about some
of these questions
investigators have previously said
Pelosi did not know de Pap when the 42
year old broke into his home why Pelosi
didn't try to flee or tell responding
officers he was in distress is unclear
so even NBC News is there this was not
just some one-off reporter giving a
little bit of commentary on the air this
was a full news report where they even
raised the questions explicitly that are
implied by the report and then the
report's gone
it's gone you can't you can't find that
video on NBC right now they took it down
that luckily we were able to get a clip
of it so it'll be on this show until
they try to take that down
it's weird that's weird isn't it of
course they deleted the report the
police have said they won't release the
body camera footage the Pelosi's are not
going to release the home security
footage
so we're left with okay I'm glad Paul
Pelosi's okay
all right at the very least
whatever occurred in the Pelosi home in
the middle of the night
it is not going to affect the midterm
elections it just hasn't had the effect
that clearly Joe Biden wanted it to have
when he gave a whole speech about it
pretty dodgy stuff pretty and it's a lot
of dodgy journalism about it there was a
good NBC news report but then it's dodgy
that they took it down speaking of dodgy
journalism would you believe that your
beloved host me me whom everybody loves
so
was just recently attacked by the
Southern Poverty Law Center
the splc is a leftist attack group their
whole job is to get us fired and it's
like Media Matters but they've been
around a little bit longer and they're a
little bit more aggressive actually even
than Media Matters and they have
something called hate watch
and hate watch just did a piece that was
on me it was on other conservatives too
I wasn't even the main object of their
ire but they did go after me pretty hard
in here and I knew they were going to do
that because I got an email from this
guy who wrote it Michael Edison Hayden
months ago said Michael we're doing a
piece it's not really about you but I
want to clarify comments that you've
made on the air and uh you know what do
you think about trans women you don't
think trans women should have the rights
to
I don't know do whatever swim on the
girls team or go to the bathroom or
whatever so I get this email I know it's
a hit piece I know this guy's a radical
leftist and I know it's absurd and I
know that they have a something called
hate watch and they're going to portray
me as the worst person in the world but
I I say I'm going to respond to this guy
and I I responded with a
I felt a thoughtful polite
uh email immediately within 24 hours and
I said uh dear Michael Edison Hayden
um you you keep using this term trans
women I'm I'm afraid I'm not familiar
with that ontological category if by
trans women you mean confused men who
believe that they're women and you're
asking me if I think that they ought to
uh have their genitals lopped off I
think that sort of thing ought to be
discouraged I think it's a violation of
the Hippocratic Oath uh the splc wanted
me to clarify do I think that
genital you know mutilation of these
confused men who think that they're
women should that be only banned in the
culture or should that be banned by the
power of the law and the power of the
state and I said even there I said you
know I'm even confused by that
distinction because in America we have
self-government so the idea at least in
theory is that we make our own laws and
we set the standards that we want to
live under within certain limits uh
articulated in the Constitution and so
there's not a whole
a bit of a difference really between
what what the people want to do in their
own society and the state because
America's supposed to have
self-government and then I even had a
little French at the end and I said to
borrow a line and adapt it from Louis
XIV in America you know we are we are
the state in America so those are I said
if you have any questions please you
know write to me what kind regard is all
the best Michael
so then he runs this piece he says
a Knowles
expressed hateful views of the lgbtq
plus Community Knowles is a pundit for
the daily wire and he used his
appearance on a Newsweek show to say
that he's within his rights to tell
adult transgender women that they're not
women
and then he quotes me from the show and
initially they said Knowles did not
respond and I said this is just a lie
this is just a total lie so I pointed it
out on Twitter that I couldn't find a
guy on Twitter the guy had blocked me
this guy who reached out to me he
blocked me and
but then finally enough people tweeted
at him that he said no no I I don't have
the email I don't have it I search my
inbox I don't have it I kept using that
phrase I don't have the email I don't
have an email from Michael Knowles and I
noticed that's kind of specific diction
he didn't say I've never received an
email from Michael Knowles he said I
don't have it now so what happened it
seems like he it seemed I I don't want
to be uncharitable or unfair but if I
were a Gambling Man I bet he did receive
the email and he deleted it so then he
can say truthfully I don't have an email
but but regardless I have the
screenshots I sent him my commentary he
still clearly didn't want to update the
article he had said listen I always
quote in in its entirety the statements
given to me by the people that I
interview and so I said okay well you
have it now and he kept going on he said
I don't have the email I said well now
you have it here it is I've just sent it
to you you have the email
and he wouldn't quote it he quoted five
words of a of five words of a random
sort of analogy in my email but he
wouldn't quote pretty much anything that
I said in my email he linked to it so
but he wouldn't I thought why why why
I realized I realized why this guy
appears to have lied about receiving my
answer in the first place and why he
refuses to quote my actual answer not
just in full but really any substantial
part of it the reason why is that the
libs
the libs rely on Republicans and
conservatives being evil awful terrible
people we just have to be the the
angriest meanest cruelest most awful
people in the world
and the thing is we're not I'm not
saying there aren't some bad guys out
there but conservatives are not actually
we're generally more content than the
libs are that's why we're conservatives
we want to conserve things you know
we're generally sort of
more balanced we tend not to you know
mutilate our bodies too much and just be
angry and shrieking at the Moon all the
time so
the libs have to censor us
they can't present the real
conservatives they have to censor us
they can't allow us to State our points
of view
that the only reason that we could
defend a defend marriage the only reason
we could defend the difference between
men and women is just because we're
hateful awful bigots but the they can't
let us explain why we actually think
these things because that will be very
attractive to voters
and what you've seen in recent years
increasingly in recent years is that
the conservatives get past Gatekeepers
and we find a way around and we present
what we actually believe and who we
actually are to the voters and the
voters like us and that's why you're
seeing a massive movement
across pretty much every demographic to
the conservatives and you're going to
see that reflected you've seen that
reflected in the polls already you'll
probably see that reflected at The
Ballot Box on Election night and so
if the liberal establishment wants to
hold on to its grip on power it's going
to have to become more nakedly
authoritarian it's going to it's not
going to be able to keep up the silly
claim that actually the libs who want to
kill all the babies and chop off the
genitals of the five-year-olds and erase
our borders and wage these wars of
empire in the middle of nowhere they're
not going to be able to maintain the lie
and the charade that they're doing this
because they're the voice of the people
okay that is falling apart and but the
libs don't want to give up their grip on
Power and so they're just going to have
to become much more authoritarian even
than they already are now it is music
Monday so the rest of the show continues
on we've got a a great song I am told
this was chosen by associate producer
Jacob
he's a rap mogul apparently it's a
conservative rap song I know I did I
didn't want to I know but hey he he says
it's really really great so we'll check
it out on music Monday I'll be chatting
with you over at the member block if
you're not already a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
oh
[Music]